дорогі друзі як я і
обіцяв тільки завершаться вибори ми Наша
команда спільна і потужна команда
європейської солідарності продовжила
пошук та доставлення в Україну найбільш
затребуваного на даний момент медичного
обладнання на цей раз це кисневі
концентратори щодо яких існує абсолютно
критична нестача в українських лікарнях
я хочу подякувати подякувати всім
гогодійникам які долучилися до цієї
справи до цієї акції акції фонду
Порошенка акції справи громад і кожного
хто надіслав свої власні гроші для того
щоби це стало можливим мені як людина
яка сама перехворіла коронавірусом
нестерпно боляче чути історії про те що
важким хворим бракує кисню про те як
люди збиваються з ніг В пошуках кисневих
концентраторів для своїх рідних близьких
друзів і не можуть їх знайти І після
того як Україна плилася в хвості в
порівнянні з іншими державами щодо
забезпечення засобами захисту щодо
тестування після того як влада проспала
проблеми нестачі кисню в лікарнях вони
ще зараз провалюють проведення
вакцинації перші вакцини за їх
твердженням мають надійти лише в
березні-квітні і забезпечені будуть по
тим угодам які владані зараз лише 2 млн
українців А що робити
решта Влада як зазвичай не дає Ні
відповіді не збирається нести
відповідальность в бюджеті наступного
року обсяг фінансів передбачений на
закупівлю вакцин Це просто смішно Це
сльози це крапля в морі від реальних
потреб навіть станом на сьогоднішній
день Влада відверто маніпулює
статистикою оскільки не вміє бути чесним
з суспільством
ми всі не знаємо реальної картини
поширення коронавірусу в Україні але на
жаль Україна займає дуже
непочесні високі місця в антирейтингу і
щодо активних хворих в антирейтингу і
щодо смертності в антирейтингу і щодо
темпів поширення хвороби А сьогодні ми
бачимо 50 кисневих концентраторів які
розраховані кожен на цілу палату дає
можливість одночасно працювати з двома
мінімум з двома пацієнтами Сьогодні я
хочу наголосити що одразу же після того
як вони були вивантажені вони поїдуть і
на фронт і на Схід і в медичні шпиталі і
в лікарні і кожен буде мати можливість
от уявить собі лише після лише
сьогоднішнього дня 100 пацієнтів будуть
мати можливість дихати в умовах коли
влада це не забезпечила і я дякую нашим
добровольцям нашим волонтерам які разом
з нами вийшли і зробили це можливим але
це лише подія сьогоднішнього дня до
кінця року ще до нас надійдуть 20
американських ее кисневих концентраторів
загальна кількість перевищить сотню і ми
будемо продовжувати роботу для того щоб
рятувати життя людей допомагати людям це
надзвичайно важливо
і слава Україні героям слава